une cité danse arena quartier développer
en ville le quartier de maurepas
les distractions pas très nombreuse bien
que des clubs existent il a donc fallu
créer quelque chose pour répondre aux
besoins de cette cité
maison de quartier
parce qu' il fallait compléter un
certain nombre de
non pas de lacunes mais c'est à partir
d'une constatation que tous les besoins
des besoins jeune homme aime adultes du
quartier n'étaient pas remplies prête
par un certain nombre pourtant
important d'associations et séchez d'une
démarche différent des associations
reçoivent reçoivent une certaine partie
de la population intéressée
pour pour des activités précises
associations sportives associations
culturelles associations
mixte parfois même sur des activités
plus manuels il restait cependant une
catégorie de personnes quand il fallait
tenir compte et c'est un peu le but de
cette maison
première démarche la démarche d'accueil
vient qui veut et les activités sont
libres
peu à peu les groupes se forment groupe
d'âge sensiblement les mêmes
généralement et de bouse à ses
semblables
troisième étape enfin à l'intérieur de
la maison de quartier les activités d'un
groupe à ce stade là le but peut être
considéré comme atteint il n'ya plus des
jeunes isolés qui traînent - bande
inoccupés mais des groupes qui se disent
très ou se cultiver ensemble
ce que vous avez vu à l'instant et le
club nature concret de jeunes enfants de
6 à 10 ans seuls ils nourrissent leurs
pigeons et leur hamster demandant
conseil lorsque sont inscrits et à serge
soubeyrand
ailleurs les adolescents discute
organise débattent de problèmes sans
doute important pour eux si l'on en juge
par leur sérieux
ou bien ce discret en jouant aux cartes
par exemple en dégustant des jus de
fruits exclusivement nous dansons
pourquoi pas
mourey
la présence de l'animateur et 10 fait
une aide lorsque l'on a besoin de lui
surveille de loin et ne s'impose jamais
pour question que l'on se pose il ne
donne pas de réponse son rôle consiste
surtout à faire trouver les réponses
parce qu'ils posent les questions
avec le relaye centre social nous
apportons un concours technique à une
activité
à notre collaboration et est
pratiquement de tous les jours mais elle
trouve une concrétisation sur les dents
une activité dans une initiative
du comité de quartier je veux parler du
club du jeudi le club du jeudi par
également de à peu près de la même
démarche à savoir que beaucoup
d'associations existions quartier les
associations
qui ont déjà beaucoup d'adhérents et
mais qui ne répondent qu'elles qu'à une
certaine catégorie des rangs ceux qui
sont déjà motivé par par une démarche
fin par une démarche sportive une
démarche culturelle ou autre et il reste
donc toute une catégorie celle dont
s'occupe le comité de quartier celle de
ceux qui ne se retrouve nulle part et
qui sont de préférence sur la rue
et il y en a encore beaucoup d enfants
dans la rue le quartier en effet une
population très dense et que peut-on
faire dans la rue à part jouer à la
bicyclette ou avec des bougies
d'où il joue aussi à la poupée mais
l'espace est limité il n'y a pas
beaucoup de terre un vendeur
j'aime ma site dans la rue mais quoi
exactement votre rôle bien on prend un
groupe d'enfants dans le cadre naturel
de son jeu et ont amusé parce qu'on ne
sait pas trop et alors vous jouez avec
des tout petits avec des moyens avec
n'importe qui c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui je prends à n'importe
quel âge parce que d'habitude on est
vieux et normalement je peux les
confettis mais on prend et qui décide
des jeux voilà quelques fois c'est
l'animatrice mais quelquefois les
enfants propose
oui d'où ils sont quand même difficile
en train n'ont pas l'habitude de jouer
et maintenant maintenant déjà plus
facile puisque compact effet il vous
connaître oui mieux il vient notre vent
debout oui nous attendent le jus be
quand on arrive on ne pourra que nous ça
se passe généralement bien très bien
vous êtes content de faire sa
une maison de quartier ce n'est pas un
éventail du club propose est organisée
c'est quelque chose de complémentaire
pour ceux justement qui rentre
difficilement dans des clubs
maison qui sert à tout le monde aux
enfants comme aux adultes qui le cube
certains jours de la semaine